hey everyone dear volume here and in
today's video we're going over the fifth
arc of chainsaw man's story this arc
here is called the bomb girl arc and
continues on where we just leave things
in the last video with denji literally
standing in the street completely
smitten and stunned after makima decided
to head home obviously the last dyke was
insanely hyped with zinji going up
against i guess one of his own fellow
hybrid devils the katana man and
definitely the best fight up until that
point in the story it really gets me
each time when i'm reading these arcs
not just in chainsaw man but also like
juicy kaizen and other goated series but
how the author has managed to actually
plan out the story so well to the point
that it feels like each new thing that
happens somehow manages to dethrone the
previous greatest moment in the last arc
and this arc here is absolutely no
exception so obviously if you are
interested in more anime explained
content just like this but for a bunch
of different series then make sure you
hit that subscribe button and also be
sure to smash that like button as well
so i know that you're all enjoying this
current chainsaw man series and
obviously want more but anyway enough of
that let's get into the bomb girl arc of
chainsaw man
so after making the leaves dingy walks
down the street happily thinking of the
date noting a charity stand dingy
donates money as a sign of his newfound
heart and is given a flower as thanks he
happily walks away munching the flower
to the complete building of the girl of
the stand while walking dingy thinks of
how making his words were able to calm
his pent-up concerns he assures himself
that he will use the wish that she
promised him and thanks on how she will
be the only girl he will ever be
romantically interested in suddenly it
begins raining and denji decides to run
for cover he tries to wait out the storm
in a telephone booth when a young woman
suddenly enters surprising him she
apologizes and begins laughing much to
his confusion gradually though her
laughter turns to tears before saying
that his face reminds her of her
deceased dog denji suddenly begins
gagging and pulls the flower out of his
throat presenting it to the girl she
thanks him and smiles and as the rain
stops she invites him to visit her
workplace a cafe called futamichi
arriving at her work she puts on an
apron and notices that denji is already
waiting for her the girl sits next to
him ordering a pair of coffees for the
two of them while drinking she laughs
and flirtatiously touches his shoulder
she then introduces herself as razor
with dingy also introducing himself okay
quick note i know i always get names
wrong here but like literally i don't
know why i don't know how to pronounce
her name it's it's a mind twister for me
right now to be honest anyway back to
the story dingy worriedly thinks of
makima as he realizes that his feelings
for rezay are growing suspiciously fast
meanwhile aki is on duty with the angel
devil hoping to kill more devils and
earn respect within the bureau so as to
be put on the gun devil task force the
angel devil complains though instead
wanting to sit and just eat ice cream
but arki warns him their lack of
cooperation will lead to the angel's
extermination considering this angel
concludes that dying is slightly more
effort than work and agrees to move
in a flashback we find makima
introducing the angel devil to aki
makima explains that the angel devil is
the most powerful hunter besides kishibe
she elaborates more that he has the
ability to absorb the life force of
anyone he touches transforming them
instead into weapons with powerful
properties going on to say that when he
was discovered he'd absorbed an entire
village later the pair stand over the
corpse of a devil that they had just
killed the angel deal discovers the
dying body of a civilian devil hunter
and aki requests that the angel devil
should kill the man painlessly but he
refuses stating that as a devil he
believes all humans should only suffer
as they die so instead arki kills the
man and the pair calmly conclude that
neither of them can get along on a
personal level over with denji he
returns back to the cafe unsure of
whether his heart lies with makima or
not as he enters razzie comments that
he's eaten here every day that week she
then invites him to sit at her table and
he mentions how he is unable to read he
reveals that the only kanji he can write
is balls causing her to crack up
laughing he states his desire to learn
how to read and hearing this rezay moves
in closer and invites him to attend
night school with her nervously and
extremely flustered denji then accepts
elsewhere a scarred half-naked man looks
down into a water-filled sink he speaks
to the typhoon devil asking why the
devil's desire they chainsaw devil's
heart from in the sink the typhoon
devil's voice emerges responding that he
doesn't need to know instead only
reminding him of the terms of the
contract which is the complete use of
its powers forever in return for denji's
chainsaw heart however the man still
isn't pleased and he goes on to tell a
story about how he killed a highly fed
chinese devil hunter by kidnapping
murdering and skinning his entire family
after that the devil hunter simply let
him kill him without even a fight later
that night deji and rezay walked through
the empty school rezzy comments that
she's scared and asks to hold dingy's
hand dingy agrees whilst also internally
apologizing to makima later and sat in
the classroom now rezay pretends to
teach dingy some simple nonsensical
facts such as oneplus one equals two and
how to write the phrase big dumpy in
english she comments on the lack of
education asking whether his life as a
devil hunter is truly good for him he
responds though that his job allows him
three square meals and a beard berezi
reminds him that those are the bare
minimal acceptable living conditions in
the first place they're noting dingy's
growing uneasiness resistance yes that
they go swimming now by the pool outside
reset strips down completely nude denji
admits he doesn't even know how to swim
but instantly strips down as well
though still filled with uncertainty
denji eventually jumps in as rezay
begins to show him how to swim
eventually it begins raining and the two
return indoors they sit inside watching
the rain and rezzy asks dinji if he'd
rather be the city mouse or the country
mouse meanwhile aki and the angel devil
are still talking
angel explains that the country mouse
lives in a safer yet less fulfilling
life whilst the country mouse lives in a
more dangerous but more enjoyable life
angela elaborates that he'd rather be a
country mouse however was brought by
makima to the city and forced to be a
city mouse at the same time dingy
concludes that he'd rather be a city
mouse as his only real desires are for
food and entertainment regardless of the
danger after hearing this reza invites
him to a food festival that is taking
place the next day she then leaves to
use the bathroom after she leaves dingy
quietly calls her so freaking cute under
his breath as rezay walks the corridor
alone she is approached by this scarred
man wheeled in a knife at the same time
dingy begins to panic as he realizes he
now sees rezay standing alongside makima
when he closes his eyes i really really
hope i'm pronouncing her name right
because in my head it just doesn't even
feel right right now meanwhile rej is
chased outside onto a rooftop she asks
who the scarred man is but he merely
responds that she has the cheese to act
as bait for dingy he then informs her
that he plans to peel her face off and
gouge out her eyes in order to torture
her and control denji as he lunges at
her she swiftly dodges his attack though
and swings onto his back and then begins
choking him out with little effort as he
slowly starts to die she sings him a
sweet russian lullaby as rosie stands up
she calmly looks down at the typhoon
devil in a nearby drain the devil
apologizes to her calling her miss rezay
and she promises to overlook its
accidents in return for removing the
scarred man's corpse swiftly she then
returns to denji with a beautiful smile
on her face the next day the two hang
out at the festival in the evening they
climb into a hill to view the fireworks
turning to him rezzy asks him to quit
devil hunting and run away with her
promising to make him happy and protect
him heavily conflicted then she asks why
rezzy wants to run away with him with
her telling him that she likes him
though denji admits he's tempted he
explains that he's grown more happy with
his current situation his increasing
position amongst the bureau as well as
better relationships with aki and power
headmits these are not things he's
willing to give up on so easily he asks
if he can still see her despite this but
she asks if he has someone else he likes
before grabbing him intensely and
kissing him however though and running
with a tradition of dingy having bad
luck he falls backwards and it is
revealed that reza had bitten off his
tongue instantly dingy moves to try and
pull his cord but rezzy swiftly slices
off his hand before he could do so
then kneeling in close and holding him
gently rosie kisses them again before
apologising and calmly telling him she
intends to take his heart but before she
can even move the actual goat who i
completely forgot about beam bursts
through the floor and grabs his best boy
denji then without hesitation fleeing
with him down the hill as he runs beam
curses air himself for not recognising
her smell the smell of a bomb
as he says she pulls the pin out of her
choker and her head and right arm
explode they then quickly reform
revealing her transform state which is
that of a bomb devil hybrid she screams
at beam calling him a thief then uses a
powerful blast ability to launch
yourself flying towards the duo crashing
in front of them seemingly in an instant
still clutching dingy beam attempts to
flee from rezay however she is able to
use powerful explosive blasts to launch
yourself in front of him and block his
path she offers to let him go in return
for denji however beam growls and
transforms into a giant shark headed
creature yet and seemingly with little
to no effort rezay touches his face
though hitting him with an explosion
knocking him down a trio of private
devil hunters then appear and report the
situation over a walkie-talkie stabbing
her fingers rose explodes the three of
them before turning back and noticing
that beam had already fled with denji
nearby at the second division's training
facility aki spas with some hunters one
hunter nomo thanks him for the training
before requesting he worked for them and
promising him a high-ranking position in
5 years as they leave the angel devil
asks aki why he didn't mention his short
life spam revealing that power informed
him of it the angel devil calls aki
lucky revealing his desire to die as so
to avoid effort
suddenly nomu rushes around the corner
requesting their aid at the entrance
they see a heavily injured bean
clutching dengue's tatted body beam
informs aki though the bomb hybrid is
coming and reveals the bomb devil to be
the gun devil's partner when aki
questions why he knows this information
beam reveals he promised mahima he
wouldn't tell under threat of death nomo
then notices a young girl a human formed
reza approaching the facility
she requests their aid claiming to have
been attacked by a devil however nomo
notes a wide smile on her face as they
move dingy and beam nomo comments that
rezay seems familiar asking aki if he
recognizes her noting that they won't
simply let her enter rezay prepares to
pull out the pin in her neck commenting
that she'll have to massacre them all
instead before rezay can attack two
hunters kaito and tanabe use an unknown
devil's ability to grow mould in her
heart and intestines stunning her as she
coughs up blood they comment that their
mold will continue to grow even if she
regenerates as the pair plant to stall
her until she is consumed in retaliation
rezzy fires a blast at her own head
decapitating herself reza's still moving
torso flings the head at the devil
hunters as he heads says boom it
releases a sudden burst and transforms
into the fully formed bomb hybrid whilst
the hunters are distracted by the attack
the torso runs towards them nomo
attempts to stop her using the fox devil
to attack however the torso dodges and
grabs him before exploding numerous
hunters are then seen dead as the
reformed rezai continues the assault
blasting away the other survivors nomo
though having survived the explosion on
him attempts to attack again yet again
though rezay dodges each hit but before
she can execute him the second division
lieutenant appears summoning khan to
swallow her whole
the success was in vain however as khan
quickly disappears leaving the bomb
devil to continue her assault meanwhile
aki prepares to drive the angel devil
the unconscious dingy and beam away from
the building he orders angel to give
blood to denji to which the angel devil
reluctantly complies but before they can
start though arkey complained of an
unknown vision he just received from the
future devil suddenly as the cast starts
rosie appears clutching the severed
heads of nomo and the lieutenants she
explains that she killed the two of them
as a sign of strength stating that she'd
rather not kill and ask in the group to
just leave denji behind and flee aki not
listening swiftly drives the car and
swerves around her attempting to escape
rezay leaps atop the vehicle with a
blast irritatedly commenting on how the
gasoline within the car will cause a
fire although before she can even attack
she is ambushed and knocked back with a
kick from the violence fame aggie leans
out of the car window shouting that he
called for backup earlier on thanking
the violence fan the fan kicks avreza
again however to a surprise she is able
to block his attack complementing the
violence fiend on its strength reserve
prepares to fight yet the theme noting
how much weaker he is calls out kabini
stating that the bomb devil is stronger
than them and it's actually time for a
tactical retreat turning around rezzy
sees kabini on the floor having actually
fallen down with an injured hip she
begins crying and begging for her life
crawling up into a ball on the floor
luckily though as she sobbed reset
spared her and chased after dingy
in the car aki continues driving down a
packed motorway looking out the window
angel sees reza moving through the sky
blasting herself towards their position
she lands on a large truck immediately
behind them as dingy awakes from his
days gasping for air aki tells the
others that as a last resort he'll ram
the car directly into her as their main
goal is to keep denji away from her
however not listening then she
transforms into the chainsaw devil
slicing his way through the car as he
begins to rampage towards her now facing
the bomb devil then she angrily screams
telling her that every woman he has ever
met has tried to kill him then
proceeding to ask why are so many people
interested in the chainsaw's heart but
not him risley asks him that her
feelings for him we're genuine causing
dingy to hesitate for a moment yet aki
yells out to him stabbing him back to
reality and telling him not to be so
damn gullible then she comments that he
no longer needs her as he actually has
makima where's they show surprise before
saying that they're two running away
together would have been meaningless if
mahima held influence over him now just
pissed off dingy yells that he doesn't
want anyone else to die because of him
and instead only plans to capture her
before he launches himself directly at
the bomb devil entering combat reset
immediately erupts destroying the truck
her and dingy was standing on being
knocked backwards into a building denji
is also punched in the face by rezay and
is flung back even further she then
begins chastising him going on to prove
her point rezzy reveals she allowed
denji to actually slice off one of her
fingers which is now caught on denji's
chain instantly the severed finger then
explodes catching denji off guard as
rezay looks into the cloud of smoke left
by the blast denji leaps out and
attempts to attack her again
nevertheless reza's reflexes proved to
be too quick as she blasts the pier up
into the sky moving through the air
razek transforms her leg into a missile
immediately launching the two back down
to the ground again and literally
tearing dingy's torso apart blow as
blood-covered civilians look on rezay
picks up denji's severed torso and
blasts it rendering it into nothing but
a heap of blood and smouldering flesh as
rezai moves through the ruined building
she steps over corpses leaving behind a
number of injured survivors it is then
revealed that that sneaky ol arki is
actually hiding amongst the corpses
pretending to be dead as rezai moves
past him he quickly stands up and slices
off her arm causing her to drop denji
aki moves him to attack rezai again
however after seeing a vision from the
future devil he instantly moves back and
begins to dodge her attacks in
retaliation whereas he transforms her
arm into a missile and hits the ground
causing a massive explosion she is
knocked back by her own blast but
luckily for arki the violence fiend
arrives managing to grab and pull him
out of the blast into safety the
violence fiend apologizes for his poor
timing but aki jokingly comments that
he's never been so glad to see a damn
devil as the two look to rezay she
pauses and asks for a timeout commenting
that she has lost a lot of blood and a
two against one fight in these
conditions is just unfair randomly the
fein agrees asking aki if they should
accept a handicap and he fights however
aki just fled out refuses rezay then
reveals her hesitation was merely a ploy
as now a monstrously massive typhoon
devil appears crashing through a nearby
building and offering to enter the fight
and assist her nearby the angel devil
moves through the rubble absorbing the
life of the dying victims moving over to
dingy's torso which is now being
clutched by the bff beam angel gives him
blood restoring our boy back to full
strength beam is delighted commenting on
how dingy is super cool angel tells
dingy he needs to choose whether he
wants to die and give reze his heart or
kill her then she thinks on this for a
moment before deciding to kill her
stating that it's an easy choice dingy
worries about reza's enormous strength
and the angel devil asks beam for advice
commenting that he seems to have a
greater knowledge of the chainsaw devil
beam suggests that denji should use his
chainsaws to move more quickly by
wrapping the chainsaws around objects
and swinging from building to building
dingy grows excited at the prospect of
expanding his power and orders being to
transform into a shark as he does dingy
jumps onto his back and uses the chains
of his chainsaw as a set of reins hoping
to control beam like a horse both beam
and the angel devil comment on this
nonsensical method of movement however
then she ignores them instead then she
sends beam charging towards the enemy as
the two move forward the typhoon devil
greets them excitedly as the combined
strength of the explosion and typhoon
send the others flying back the violence
thing comments that they can do nothing
now but simply watch the struggle
between denshi beam rezay and the
typhoon devil in the battle dingy moves
in and is able to slice off the bomb
devil's leg but the typhoon devil gives
her some of his juice healing her both
dingy and rezay express excitement over
the insanity of the conflict as the
flurry continues the angel devil is
blasted back aki grabs his shirt yeah he
also begins to lose his grip on the
signpost he was holding onto for dear
life angel calls out for him telling him
to just let go as he has already
accepted his death as aki begins to lose
his grip on the angel devil's shirt the
devil closes his eyes and thinks of a
young woman from his past suddenly arki
grabs the devil's hand and pulls him
back into safety pissed off though the
angel devil angrily asks him why arki
grabbed his hand as doing so cost him
another two months of his already short
life span aki responds that if the angel
devil were to die he'd rather it would
done at a distance as he has said enough
of watching people die in front of his
eyes back in the conflict dingy is able
to easily slice the typhoon devil to
shreds losing the sight of reza though
she attacks the pier from above blasting
dingy and beam into the ground crawling
out of a semi-conscious beam's mouth
danger reveals their being took the
brunt of the blast now standing up he
and rezay finally face just one another
on a rooftop playfully she asks him to
give up however our boy the legend the
freaking chainsaw man responds that he
doesn't wanna hearing this and pissed
rosie flicks a small blast at denji
erupting his right arm and igniting him
with fire moving in closer an irritated
frizzy asks him to accept death she
comments that he has nowhere else to run
but dingy responds saying that she had
actually made a mistake pointing out the
ocean that is stationed behind them
reminding her that she had taught him
how to swim she flicks another blast at
his other arm and as the smoke clears it
is revealed that dingy managed to keep
the arm attached to his torso by
connecting the chain between his
shoulder and forearm flinging the chains
at reset he manages to wrap her up
before suddenly leaping into the ocean
with her and because she is unable to
explode whilst wet she sinks to the
bottom and becomes unconscious
the next morning now after the fight she
reawakens in a human form lying next to
denji and a sleeping beam on a nearby
beach she asks him why he revived her
and he responds that he did it for his
own sake as he felt that allowing her to
be captured or killed would haunt him
she reminds him that she could easily
kill him to what she playfully responds
if i'm going to die at least let it be
at the hands of a beautiful woman rizzy
begins to laugh telling him that she
never really liked him in the first
place and every flirtatious interaction
from her was just part of her plan as
she starts to leave though then she asks
to leave with her and go on the run
confused in questioning him he tells her
that he genuinely likes her and reminds
her that even if all her comments were a
lie she still taught him how to swim
which implies some kind of genuine
affection rezay moves closer to dingy
before swiftly snapping his neck and
walking away as she leaves him lying
there dingy calls out to her inviting
her to the cafe that day at noon as she
changes her mind about running away
skipping forward now to later in that
day denji packs his bags and heads out
to the cafe
elsewhere aki and kishibe watch as they
clean up for the previous night's fights
go on kishibe tells aki a russian urban
legend of a ussr military branch that
performs human testing on children
explaining this story to be true
khasheba reveals that rezai was actually
one of those children with her true name
ben morimoto nearby rezai moves to a
train station planning to run away
however while sitting there at the
station she chooses not to actually
enter the train and instead to walk to
the cafe that denji is at as she moves
through an alleyway towards it she
begins to smile with anticipation
however suddenly a mob of mice run by
her feet forming a large pillar in front
of her a voice is heard from within it
as the mice fall away it is revealed to
be makima she states that she refers the
country mouse in reference to the
conversation between rezay and dingy a
few nights prior nevertheless makima
reveals her reason for liking the
country mouse as it's based on her
enjoyment of capturing and killing them
an activity she describes as giving her
peace of mind rosie moves to pull the
pin on her neck however in an eerily
similar way of what she did to dingy her
arm is instantly obliterated before she
can even react making my moves and hits
her in the chest knocking her back
mid-stumble she is also impaled by a
spear thrown from a rooftop by the angel
devil as reza slowly begins to bleed out
makima takes her hand and looking at the
cafe rezay thinks of denji wondering on
the reason she didn't even kill him on
their first date was it also because
like dingy she never been to school
either and was just as excited as he was
makima tells the angel devil that he was
supposed to bring aki with him but also
comments that it was nice to leave him
behind as he wouldn't have reacted well
to executing a woman angel agrees before
looking down at her mouse and asking it
if the city is a nice place inside the
cafe dingy sits despondently clutching a
bouquet of flowers
the owner speaks to him promising that
another girl will eventually come along
one who is just perfect for him as he
says this the door then opens and power
walks in she shouts that she followed
dingy sent to the cafe having been
allowed back to work then she lets out a
low disheartened sigh as power sits next
to him thinking that the bouquet dinji
was holding as for her power demands
that he'd give her the flowers and as
the two look at each other then she
quickly shoves them all into his mouth
scoffing them down smiling
what fancy seeing you guys out here in
the middle of absolutely nowhere well
honestly i think the bomb girl arc here
is definitely the most exciting and
probably like heartfelt throughout the
series so far i know hermino's death in
the last arc with the katana man arc was
extremely heartfelt and extremely sad
but i think this ikea hits differently
with like dingy and the kind of emotions
that he goes through with reza and
everything it's just like it's an
absolute mind trip that this character
has to go through and realizing that you
know like maybe everything is going to
be okay on the other side but for now
it's absolutely and this dude is
getting rick rolled at every corner
every single time something seems to be
going right for him it's just
like it's just this is just wrong it's
not going right i really really can't
wait till i get into the international
assassin assassination arc or whatever
it's called coming up next because
honestly here i think rizzay for me was
almost my favorite character i think
introduced up until this point the
dynamics that she had with dingy and
this this idea of like getting him to
want to run away from where he currently
is in the even the situation that he
currently has and how he thinks it's
good actually isn't that great and it's
a normal thing that every single person
throughout the country should actually
have and i absolutely love that kind of
like dynamic there it's making dingy
like kind of realize that yeah he's had
it from the very beginning and he's
finally got normality but that normality
isn't even normal for him at the moment
and i i really really like that and i
hope i hope throughout the series i i
know it sounds weird rosie is 100 dead
probably but i hope she kind of doesn't
i hope like mark him is like yeah you're
coming back with me like chucks are on
his shoulder brings her back to the lab
and she's part of the crew or something
because
ah dude who powers and everything
that she does is so so cool i really
really really liked her character but
honestly i'd love to know what you guys
all think down in the comment section
below every freaking devil at the moment
seemed to have a backup partner who's
feeding some of them feeding some of
them they're like you know some of their
drip or whatever you want to say but you
know obviously i hope you all have
enjoyed the video there's actually a car
coming down the road in front of you
right now so i probably should do
the end of the video right here so
obviously if you have enjoyed the video
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and if you are new around here i want to
keep up to date with the latest chainsaw
man arcs or just other arcs in general
from a variety of different series then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
even though i just see that and hit the
like button as well i've it all
up the car is coming too quickly but
anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i
will see you all in there but bye
[Music]
you